it's happening man this is cool i know
it's a dream come true
so welcome back to the 20th ever episode
of the iced coffee hour so far
we've made something like 5 600
something something crazy like that now
from the podcast in ad revenue uh meet
kevin's episode by far
wins i think his episode has made like
600 so far
so kevin thank you so much really
appreciate it
and today we have guests get a cut of
this or is that uh absolutely not you
can keep
this twenty dollar bill right there okay
at the end oh yeah i'll take yours
i'll take it i'll take it you could keep
that but today we actually we have an
amazing guest
i say that every episode but but this
one i mean it uh
[Music]
what uh how do i i don't even know how
to introduce
you because you've changed the channel
name uh so let's just say this
i want to call you a viral internet
sensation
uh business owner and now
just a little bit of everything i would
say
yeah a renaissance man renaissance man
uh what's up guys my name is kong
i am the founder of
an old channel called simple pickup i've
since changed the name to kong fam
i also now run a venture back startup
called jump cut where we make
online courses our most popular one is
called viral academy where we teach
people
how to start and grow their own youtube
channel so
i actually have been watching your
channel now for almost 10 years you
started out with a channel it's called
simple pickup where you made these
really hilarious i don't want to even
call them skits because they weren't
skits but
you would pick different ideas or
concepts to go to
say to say to women on the street and
then see if you can get their phone
number
yeah yeah the concept was um you know i
i grew up as a very introverted like shy
guy very you know typical asian family
where
you don't really voice you're like you
can't be too loud you got to keep to
yourself
so i had a hard time um basically
dating for for a very long time and it
wasn't until probably around college
that
i kind of went on this almost like
journey
of of not only trying to like get girls
because
that sounds very surface level but it
was more of like
trying to be a better me trying to be a
more confident person
showing my actual real self and not
being afraid of that versus just like
being the shy guy who stays in the
corner all the time
um so i went through that journey it
changed my life and i wanted to make a
channel that
um where where people could see that
look these things that you think are
really
difficult for example going up to
somebody who you think is attractive
and and trying to start a conversation
with them it's really not that hard
it's actually quite easy um so we turned
that into a youtube channel essentially
and uh
yeah you know who had that idea to turn
that into a channel
i think uh well my
my college roommate at the time jesse
and i were
like entrepreneurs at heart and we would
always think like what can we do as
how can we start a business right and we
had all these ideas um
a couple of them failed that we tried to
do but the one that worked was making a
youtube channel so this was right when
youtube was started paying people um you
know they just they had just come out
with it like a year or two ago
and we said hey why don't we jump on
this bandwagon because we watch youtube
way more than
than than tv or movies that was me yeah
yeah exactly right so it's like i think
i can know
i think i do this i think i think i know
what works on youtube what goes viral
um so we put out a video and instantly
it got
about i want to say fifty thousand
hundred thousand views something like
that
and then we said i think this is it um
spent that whole summer
uh spent that whole summer making more
videos got a bunch of viral hits and
then literally the semester after that
we dropped out of school so the first
video you ever made got 50 000 views
right off the bat
so quote unquote first we made a couple
ahead
like before that that i believe we put
out but it just
one i knew that it sucked as soon as it
came out and two it didn't get any views
so technically yes it was the first
video in the sense that like
we really put it out and then we pushed
it yeah well yeah we push and try to
promote it whereas the other videos we
just kind of put it up there and we're
like
um okay this is not really that great
how much did you make from that first
video how much did 50 000 views pay back
then
not that much dude i look at your cpms
today
and like the people doing it today i'm
like what you get that much money
um so back then like we would be
so so our content was also a little bit
like we would swear in the videos
so you know sometimes we would get
flagged i would say on average we got
about
one dollar to 1.50 cpm so every thousand
views we would get about a dollar to a
dollar fifty
wow yeah what was that best at best
it was like we signed a contract with
machinima at that time
and they gave us three dollars so that
was the highest we ever got wow and that
was like a good deal
but you were getting on some of these
videos tens of millions of views you had
a few of them that were over 10 million
views yeah yeah and then for those
videos the cpm actually went higher for
some reason
i guess it's just because um more
advertisers are
are advertising on on viral videos i
don't know um but
it would never go above like two dollars
cpu okay
what was the first video that you
released the one that was successful
what was this we got to be pg rated oh
yeah surprise can i swear on this
podcaster
uh not i would prefer not okay if the
occasional slip
jack edited out we we want to keep our
high cpm so we don't want to be black
yeah
we want to be as smart family friendly
as possible we've had me on then
we just got to be getting how about i
you i
almost can't explain it okay so
basically it was called
asian um asian
private part pickup and uh i would have
to say
variations of this private part word in
conversation casually
um before getting somebody's number so
for example
i would say hey jack um uh
where can i jeez i'm i'm gonna butcher
it now there's no way to say it
yeah there's really no way to say it
it's it's yeah yeah
no here's the interesting thing in all
seriousness
i don't think you could make that video
today
i think with this environment that would
not be okay yeah because back then
it was tens of millions of views now you
couldn't get away
and say a lot of the things that you
could back then well you could
you just need the stones to to to keep
it up there and not
you know apologize for things i think
people are just um you know there's
definitely this wave of people who are
really sensitive about these things
um but i know plenty of comics plenty of
people who are still making really
outrageous content dave chappelle is one
famous example right you watch his
specials
he's very very polarizing he's you know
to the point where it's it's
somewhat offensive um but he stands by
he says
i don't care i'm not going to apologize
for anything i say on this stage
so i think you can still do it okay but
you're going to get a lot of heat for it
for sure
fair enough but uh so back then you were
making these
making these videos and then when was
the point that you realized
like you're gonna move out i remember
you got a house in mid
city l.a
you mean our first place it was in van
nuys i believe
okay um so this like really part of
la for people that don't live there well
some of it
okay um but the neighborhood we were in
was there was literally bars on people's
doors
um but uh you know we said look let's
commit to this let's let's
do it um it was four dudes that lived in
a two-bedroom apartment
where water would turn brown when we
turned it on um in the morning
and uh we did that for about i want to
say like nine months or something like
that
you know just toughed it out started
making money and uh eventually we were
able to move into a bigger and better
house and yeah
and actually live comfortably did you
graduate college at that time
no no dropped out so you were in college
and then things were going well with
the youtube channel so then you just
decided to drop out and pursue this and
move to van nuys with these other guys
yeah yeah exactly and you know i think
that's the thing that people get
really wrong too is that like they
always say like hey look at kong or like
whatever
whoever like they didn't go to college
they dropped out of college
i think if you're going to college you
should
do something on the side and once it
takes off then drop out
guess who just dropped out i don't know
if you've seen jack just dropped out
i heard yeah yeah i heard
congratulations but you know you're
doing
really well yeah you're you have
something that's going on for you right
now and
you know things you know your things are
picking up you can see the trajectory
and i think that's a good time to drop
out but
you know if a lot of people always ask
me on instagram for some reason like
should i drop out of college i hate it
blah blah blah
well start something on the side first
and then do it so yeah to answer your
question
um you know we we spent that whole
summer basically trying to get as many
views as possible trying to make money
and um it was only once we got traction
that we dropped out of college
and then you created a program uh that
was a monthly right five dollars a month
yeah yeah how much how much did that
make
i'm so curious because now we can get
all the details yeah so basically um
for people that don't know uh we had
this kind of almost like entertainment
channel where we would do these almost
like prank videos but we're
you know cheesy pickup lines getting
girls phone numbers
and we had a subscription product on the
back end where we would actually give
advice give uh uh more of a
in-depth have a more in-depth discussion
on
how to be more confident right how to
get more dates um so at first we charged
five dollars a month for it
and it eventually turned into i believe
37
a month how much were you making how
many people pay five dollars a month
when we first launched it we made
fifteen thousand dollars
for that month the first month or it
might have been more than that i forget
um but like it was under it was under 50
for sure and that was between four
people
yes yeah that's correct so it's like it
sounds like a lot of money but
considering all our expenses and when we
share it it really wasn't that much
but over time we started building that
more and more
we added more features to it we added a
community feature we added podcasts
things like that
uh increased the price of 37 a month and
at its peak
i want to say we were doing about um
two two and a half million per year on
on
on that just that yeah just just that
program how many people split that
sorry sorry it was gosh i'm getting my
this was like seven
eight years ago right um i want to say
it was two to two and a half million
dollars per year
that plus um our youtube and brand deals
but
80 of it was coming from this program
so only about 10 of our revenue was
coming from ad revenue
so you turn this in a few years into a
three million dollar
your business yeah yeah essentially and
i think you know if we stuck with it we
could have grown it into a really really
big company but
i think at one point i you know the
things that we were doing
within that community and also on
youtube started getting redundant
it started uh we were kind of doing the
same thing over and over again but just
rehashed in a different way and i just
stopped being
fulfilled by that i felt like the
message we wanted to get across to
you know lonely guys around the world
had already been accomplished
and um i wanted to do something bigger
you know as an entrepreneur i'm sure
you know as well as anybody like you
always want to do better like you don't
want to just do the same thing over and
over
you're going to start a second channel
you're going to start this podcast like
you just want to do more and more
so i think for me it was starting a
business that uh
that could could have more impact on the
world number one and two
um be a bigger home run if you will
then i noticed you s you uh this is
great oh coffee by the way
and you know i always i always judged
you because i was like
there's no way this is better than
phil's coffee that i get for five
dollars
but you know you might have converted me
you might have converted
this is not paid i didn't pay you to say
i didn't give you a script to read
this is your real reaction and you know
what you actually used a light cream to
coffee ratio i would have gone a little
bit heavier
on the cream enhance some of the flavors
yeah yeah the cinnamon toast crunch
flavor that we have
but i'm glad you enjoy it this is uh
this is a business opportunity right
here we'll talk after
deal grams graham's coffee 20 cent iced
coffee
but uh you started then after all of
that jump cut studios
yeah i saw your ads yeah yeah a lot of
people a lot of ads yeah
we ran a ton of ads like literally
millions of dollars
so explain explain what jumpcutsooty is
so jumpcut studios um
well it used to be called jump cut
studios then we change it to just jump
cut
the original goal of jump cut was
to create online courses that didn't
that weren't boring because if you look
at the world of online courses right now
it's basically a lot of people who are
just talking to the camera
right there's maybe some some some like
nice powerpoint thing going on
but that's pretty much it and you know
coming from the world of youtube
we were like this this is when we were
transitioning from simple pickup we
wanted to come up with like what's our
next big
business idea and coming from the world
of making viral videos we thought
we could do better than that these guys
making like online courses are so
boring and i thought that there was a
really big opportunity here essentially
to
um to to to help educate people in a
really fun way you know you see people
doing like that
doing that kind of stuff on youtube all
the time that's why i got these tattoos
it's inspired by
kurzkazat in a nutshell because they
made
science and physics and astrology really
really interesting to the average people
to the point where they're getting tens
of millions of views per video
and so we said why don't we do that and
we can bring the world of
youtube into online courses to make it
more entertaining so that was the
premise
of of the of the um of the company
in 2016 we went through y combinator
raised about
1.8 million dollars in venture funding
to get this company started incredible
yeah yeah that's a lot of funding for
like it was a wild ride
it was a wild ride well it's no sorry
sorry why combinator only give us
i want to say 120 oh 5 000 okay that's
that seems to be
yeah yeah yeah and then they have this
thing called demo day where you pitch to
investors and
and why do you need so much investor
capital for that we
started a course with nothing why do you
need so much money on that
yeah you had the audience i mean all you
had to do is just mention it on the
channel and
so we did it okay and then we got some
traction and that's why we were able to
raise
1.8 million dollars why raise why give
give away some some of the equity in it
so because um because
the production that we wanted to do was
gonna cost a lot of money
so i'll give you an example we filmed a
course with justin khan the founder of
twitch
right um he sold his
you know worked on twitch worked on
justin.tv and then turned it into twitch
and then sold it to amazon for like a
billion dollars we did a course with him
really cinematically we interviewed a
bunch of other entrepreneurs some some
investors as well
had some really nice motion graphics on
there really great b-roll that we filmed
and that whole course costs uh cost us
about five hundred thousand dollars
approximately geez yeah um so that just
gives you the scale of how and
we didn't even get to do all the things
we wanted wow but that just gives you
the scale of how
how much it would cost to do something
like that so what was that exactly for
cause i'm still a little confused on
what exactly jump cut was
was it like uh a company that would help
people that create courses make the
courses more entertaining
no sorry yeah so let me let's let's do a
little bit more high level here
um it was an online business school
think about it like that
so one of the courses was this one
called art of the startup where justin
khan was teaching how to start a startup
get venture funding find a co-founder
all that stuff
our most popular course the one that you
saw a lot of ads for
was called viral academy that we've
changed the name a couple of times
throughout the
the years but that's that's what it's
most known as which teaches people how
to start and grow their own youtube
channel that's what i did the youtube
creator academy linked down below in the
description
very similar yeah different yeah
different than the youtube one because
the youtube one kind of gives you like a
really high level of how to do it
but ours really goes into kind of like
the frameworks that you can use to make
really great content how much was that
um so expensive right i think it was not
if you got in at the beginning it was
twenty dollars a month
okay so some people are still subscribed
for twenty dollars a month
is our content still being produced to
the not anymore
no so we've updated it like three or
four times already
um and now i think it's the best that it
could be uh but
it is it used to be a thousand dollars
yeah um now we've lowered it we have a
lot of sales that that lowered to about
500.
okay yeah wow how much did that make i'm
just i'm curious
how much it made how much of that you
saved where you spent your money
no and um you know this is a cautionary
tale for all the entrepreneurs out there
we were very caught up in like
the startup mentality okay right um so
for me i didn't care like i'm not
somebody who cares about money if i make
over let's say get out yeah i know right
i'm on the wrong podcast take this away
okay
no but like if i make more than let's
say a hundred thousand dollars a year
i'm like totally set i'm happy i don't i
have enough to travel
um um and i can eat out with my friends
without worrying about it i'm totally
fine
what i want to do is i want to build a
big company and and and
you know look back and kind of think of
it as my legacy almost
sure right so that's uh that's
a blessing and a curse um it's a
blessing in the sense that you'll move
fast at any cost but it's a curse in the
sense that
you know we over extended basically what
we
believed we were capable of doing and
ended up with a business model that was
not
built for that kind of growth so going
back to your question how much money did
we make
i might be getting these numbers a
little bit wrong but 2016 that's the
year we went through y combinator we did
about
two two million dollars in in revenue
okay
um the year after that 2017 we did about
four million
might be like 4.5 and then the year
after that that was our best year
um which was 2018 and we did 12 million
in revenue
wow and about 5 million of that was
profit in the sense that we had no clue
what to do with like we wanted to spend
all of our money
so that we don't have to pay taxes right
like amazon style because if you make
five million dollars you're paying
like well trump trump lowered the taxes
that year
so he made america great again it's
still it's still half
california state income tax
it's half it was yeah it's about half
but it was less than it was before that
so sure
you know we literally paid like two
million dollars in taxes
right um but uh our goal was to to be
able to spend
more than we made so then the next year
2019
we're still in this growth mode thinking
all right we're this is great
everything's going fine
we continue to to ramp up uh ad spend we
hired a ton of people
we actually hired a hiring manager to
help us hire more people
we had 100 people at working for jump
cut at one time
almost 100 people it was like 85 people
wow um
and the issue was that our business
model wasn't sustainable
because you have to keep churning what's
the new thing right exactly
exactly and the other courses that we
made weren't as big of a hit
as viral academy so um you know
to niche that's what i learned on mine
you gotta you gotta appeal to
the broad demographic out there yeah
yeah exactly and i think just like the
the subject matter of making youtube
videos was so
you know foreign at the time no one was
really making a course for this
that we were pretty much the only people
that were doing it yep
um and so so eventually you know we
started to launch more courses and we
realized that was a one-off that works
really really well
and we grew our team a lot banking on
the fact
that all these other courses would work
just as well now when we launched the
other courses
they worked well but they didn't work
well enough to support an 85 person team
right and so unfortunately um you know
late last year i basically had to lay
off a ton of a ton of
a ton of people and um we made the
decision to essentially
uh stop being a high growth startup
right and we said look
this is a nice small business let's keep
it cash flow positive
and we'll work on another project that
has better product market yeah
that's why i love the low overhead model
for really
yeah until we until honestly about three
months ago
it was really just me jack is now as of
uh when about a month now two months has
it been full time
since uh august 1st since august first
full time
yeah got a jack i highly recommend
everyone get a jack by the way
jack of all trades but i just keep
everything as simple as it could be
no office space don't have to pay for
anything it's just the same camera
buy it use towels on the lights just buy
things once
at one point i think my overhead um some
of the best months i've ever had was
like three four hundred bucks
total yeah all my overhead no i totally
get it like when we were running simple
pickup that's kind of how we operated
too we just wanted we just said look
let's put as much money in our pocket as
possible because i grew up poor so i was
like
that like i want this money um and uh
it's different though when you when you
run a startup and you have investors
right because now
you're sending out an update every month
and they're going why isn't growth
as as good as last month why why aren't
you doubling your sales why don't you
hire this person let's get on a call so
there's this like pressure and then
there's there's
external pressure from other peers who
are you know doing really really well so
they're kicking
dude calm you could do better than this
i'll help you i'll introduce you to the
right people so there's this kind of
like pressure you know
the fire under you grow grow grow under
um any circumstances
and um again i think it's a blessing and
a curse but for us
overall because the business we
overestimated how
how how good the business model was it
ended up
not as great for us yeah why did you
need 85
employees because realistically i mean i
have no idea how big of an operation
jump cut was but for graham and i like
graham created the course
and then now to maintain the course it's
very pretty low maintenance for the
courses at least on his behalf
like why do you what were the 85 people
doing
yeah i would say most of them so out of
that 85
about 50 of them were doing customer
service um so we so we scaled up
50 a lot of customer service people in
the philippines
um they spoke really great english but
you're only paying them like you know
four or five bucks an hour which is
above the median pay uh there
and so so um most of them were on
customer service because it's a pretty
pricey course
and you know it's not like your course
where people watch your videos
and then they're like this is cold
traffic that we're running ads to that
we're saying hey go check out this
course and buy it so they have a ton of
questions
and we train these uh customer service
representatives to essentially
answer all these these really nuanced
questions you know what i actually heard
from somebody else they said
if you don't get a 10 refund rate
you're not selling hard enough because
the sale is supposed to be
so impactful that people are just
supposed to buy it without thinking
about it
and when that happens you get about a 10
refund rate so if you get below that
you need to ramp up your marketing and
sell harder believe it or not
i don't do that but i'm just saying
that's from a marketing standpoint
that's typically what they recommend
yeah um we we kind of operated like that
for a while we had a pretty high refund
rate but um
we we made we made a change to our
refund policy where
you can only get a refund now if you do
all of the assignments
right and i think that changed you know
that lowered our conversion rate but
that also
drastically lowered the refund rate as
well um and the assignments aren't hard
to do like
people do it in like two hours and then
send it to us and we give them a refund
yeah
don't don't tell my co-founder i said
that did you see a serious change when
you would spend more money on ads like
there was a
direct correlation on return on like
your ad spend
expenses because when graham did he did
a video
where he launched ads for his for his
course
roi i think at the the peak one was a 32
time roi so for every dollar i spent i
got 32 dollars back
why didn't you continue running it i
didn't want to be the guy i didn't want
to be that guy yeah people left the
class
that graham doesn't like dislike yeah i
got
i got a big back i don't want to say big
backlash because
part of it was just an honest experiment
to be like hey let's let's do
i thought i had two different types of
ads they ran against one had a
lamborghini in the background and one
did not
the one that did not have a lamborghini
had a much higher conversion rate and i
made a video yeah
showing you that like it's much better
to be honest and and just up front
and it's about like flashy things in the
back but i didn't want to be that guy
running ads i knew that would just
hurt my credibility yeah i think in the
short term i can make a lot of money but
i'm worried that like
what would that do to the perception of
me that i am running ads
yeah i think you know that's one of the
the problems we ran into as well where
people would like be like these guys
sell too hard they're super scammy
whatever so
um i totally get it you know we made a
lot of money but like
at what cost right now when people see
my face they're like oh that's the guy
that i see on ads all the time um so
yeah it's a double edged sword do you
ever get recognized
from the ads and not from your actual
channel be like i saw your ad
yeah yeah i get more i get recognized
more from my ads now than i get
recognized from my
my old channel do people recognize you
and go up to and use the pickup lines
that you had previously used because i
feel like that would be something that
that that would happen
sometimes yeah yeah sometimes and um
it's it's
it's fun um but not when i'm with my
family
come on i'm trying to have dinner with
my mom here like yeah yeah
that's funny so what are you working on
now um
yeah so now we are we're still running
jump cut you know we're still running
ads
um and and still making money off of the
the courses but the the there's two
projects that
i think are are more in turn
in line with what we're trying to do
long term so one of them is a creative
agency
um so now we're making ads for other
people uh if you think about
like poopery or squatty potty um stuff
like that
uh have you heard of those squatty potty
okay yeah sure we basically
it's like well no they had a really
viral ad oh they did yeah where
where they would be like um this guy's
literally eating like a like an ice
cream cone from a unicorn
oops sorry fat um okay so you can put a
funny image on the screen
unicorn you can even use their b-roll
unicorn poops into this ice cream cone
and a guy eats it and he's like you can
make your poops better with squatty
potty um and so anyway this went super
viral i can't believe you guys never
seen it no
uh anyway we're gonna make ads like that
for other brands um so right now we're
working with a company that makes pro
like custom probiotics where they
literally you know you send them a
sample of your poop and they give you
custom probiotics
oh my god wow yeah it's it's pretty it's
pretty fascinating
gosh imagine giving that to someone as a
gift imagine sending it to the wrong
address
you mix up your mail and like send it
off to your aunt or something yeah
yeah so that's one thing that we're
doing oh you gotta
turn the cameras off we got 32 to one
huh
on the return on ad spin
crazy dude yeah instagram was the
highest
yeah so i spent nothing so i made more
money
on instagram believe it or not than i
did from the ads with zero money spent
yeah
so anyway uh so what was the second
thing
oh yeah so the second thing we're
working on is um a little bit
i don't know if i should actually say it
it's basically a uh linkedin
for video creators yeah cool
um now i think we're gonna be getting
into the really interesting segment
um i would say you're a bit of a dating
expert
mm-hmm jack is whoa i'm single i'm going
to put you on the spot here
we need to give jack some dating advice
he's turning right here i wouldn't say
i'm a leading expert as much as i
am very uh comfortable with myself
when it comes to like meeting new people
right so uh
i think dating expert means like oh he's
really he can get any girl he wants
that's totally not true i get rejected
all the time
um and uh yeah but what
are you you know what's the goal right
now what's your journey look like
he's gonna have so many women hitting
him up down the in the dm oh
yeah uh every time we mentioned this
yeah have you guys
mentioned that he's single on on yes and
it's okay fair share of messages
all right all right anyway so explain
this
um i guess i'm not looking for anything
uh
specific you know uh i'll take
i'll take a girlfriend you know if
that's just like any any girlfriend
anybody yeah anyone if there's anybody
out there
please no i don't know
i'll take a girlfriend i like stability
i'm a fan of stability
yeah yeah what what do you what how did
you
okay how did you go from being uh uh
like a shy shy reserved person
how did you make that change did you do
that yourself or did you have influence
to teach you how to
we're going to title this video
something like how to get a girlfriend
or something like that so
let's let's give some advice to
everybody watching who doesn't have a
girlfriend or
a boyfriend like this card's full we'll
teach you how to get boyfriends and
girlfriends
so everyone will have lovers that's true
um all right where were we how to get a
girlfriend boyfriend how did you come
out of your shell
oh yeah make that change did you have
influence
yeah so i mean i you know i was inspired
by this book called the game
like a while ago where this guy kind of
went on the same journey as me where
he was he started at this as this like
geek
nerd guy and then like became like a
pickup artist
and uh essentially became became uh this
rock star and now he's a very famous
writer
so um neil strauss if you guys don't
know so you know i kind of went
through the same thing uh literally
almost exactly
like how he described in the book except
you know with various various nuances
and at the end of the day it was just
putting myself out there and getting
comfortable with the facts that some
people just aren't going to like you and
that's
totally fine and some people are going
to love you so i think
you know whenever people ask me to give
them like a one sentence piece of advice
i always say just be really comfortable
in your own skin like i think people
make the mistake of
always trying to impress when they meet
someone or always trying to impress when
they match with someone on tinder
but i think you know telling them
upfront
what your interests are if even if
they're really weird showing your
personality
what is interesting you mean like like
music taste what if you have really
boring interests
yeah like personal finance per se no no
so yeah so that's what you might think
where it's like personal finance sounds
kind of boring
but if you put that on your tinder
profile right um
i think that's a very very strong way to
get people who are into that as well and
be like yo i love personal finances yeah
but basically you have what's your fico
score
you have a pool of people right and then
as soon as you say oh yeah
like personal finance is what goes on in
my mind like 95 of the time
all of a sudden that pool of people
becomes
a water droplet yeah but you're assuming
that you could have gotten those pool of
people anyway
right like no you're right the reality
is sorry not you but like the reality is
no one's gonna attract everybody i think
the the way to really get the person who
really likes you and that you also
really enjoy
spending time with is putting those
things out there at the beginning now
i'm not saying
put i love personal finance in your
profile there's better ways to say it
right
so what if you said something like
things that really turned me on like
something something
and a high fico score like that's a kind
of more clever way to do it where it's
not so aggressive
like i would be funny uh for yukon to
review his
tinder profile do you want to do that or
we could cut this out
if you do you want to is that are you
are you a good yeah sure
connoisseur yeah i think i think i'm i'm
pretty decent
okay all right
one second all right so we're gonna
review
jack's tinder right now and um
give you my honest thoughts uh let me
just double check it beforehand to make
sure
this means you're gonna have i'll just
look at the
the profile oh no you want to read the
message
i mean if you want me to read the
messages i'll read them i'll get you a
lot of views for sure
i did that one time with uh my friend
arya reading his tinder messages
um and uh and um it just blew up for
some reason
because people just love watching that
could that could be a good title
congress jackson all right work with a
youtuber lives in santa monica
less than a mile away yes i am that guy
that did that one thing
see i had a different bio but it was
like hey come on the podcast
but no girl wanted no girl wanted to so
so i just removed that and i was like
well i have to have something so that
was the first thing that came i didn't
put a lot of thought in yeah initially
we wanted jack to match a tinder date
and then bring a tinder date on the
podcast
but it didn't work that's great
that would be hilarious i would totally
watch that okay so first thing i
wouldn't say
work with a youtuber just say um i make
viral videos
i make viral videos yeah you don't think
it's a little bit overly conscious
yeah they're like what kind of videos
you make i'd link them the podcast
okay okay fine so that makes sense um
i would say um host
of host of uh what's this called iced
coffee podcast yeah
but also i feel like that's not an
accurate representation of the work that
i do this is like
this i would consider a pass and passion
project what if he just says
works work at graham steffen
that's bad yeah knows graham stefan
personally no no i honestly i think you
should do it and then
and then they're going to look it up and
be like oh wow this gets pretty decent
views
uh i feel like that's just like a
unnecessary flex
you know if you will like i i don't like
to be
uh is that braggadocious to say like
you know what i mean if you want to you
can add a joke in there just put like
um the the guy i work for makes a lot of
money
yeah my boss makes a lot of money
yeah yeah like there's a way you can
make it so if you don't feel good about
that if you don't feel like that's
part of your personality you can just
you can say something that's a little
bit more
um a little bit more like
self-deprecating humor but you're still
you're still you're still flexing that
okay
but like you saying work with a youtuber
is like already the same thing
in my opinion you think so yeah it's
like the same thing
except this one you're trying to use
someone else's credit instead of
instead of being confident about your
own worth huh
right that's true because you do a lot
of editing a lot of really good editing
a lot of really good ideas
but you are the co-host of this podcast
okay anyway this is my opinion take it
with a grain of salt because i think
everybody has their own personality and
i think it's it's more important to be
genuine than it is to like do the right
thing or like
you know whatever it is um that's just
music i don't think that's super
significant
oh no it's significant um yeah put so
i would change your your bio to
something that explains more about you
like this doesn't tell me and yeah why
exactly it was supposed to be uh
it's supposed to like i thought it would
be the people would see it they'd be
like
oh my gosh what is it who is this guy i
would never have thought that
yeah yeah i like it stop provoking it
not at all no
yeah you should just they think i'm a
loser like i think
i think the best ways to to do it that
i've seen work really well
is um talk about your interest and what
you like but like write it in a really
creative way
right so um in one of the guides that we
put out a long time ago
um one of the one of the examples we
gave was like instead of saying like i
like to travel you just say um
anyway so that's never really true what
i would put is like something along the
lines of um
i love going to i love eating food at
third world countries
right trying the food there huh so it's
like very specific
and it's not it's not like and i do i
love vietnam i love thailand i love you
know
um all the southeast asian countries um
but it's specific enough to where it's
interesting
and and you're not just saying i like
travel it's an interesting yeah it's
actually yeah
yeah so it's like you want to be you
want to show them tell them your
interest but you don't want to be
generic
you also leave them with a little
something too exactly yeah so then it's
like if they really
enjoy it's like what what foods have you
tried there right right it's something
that doesn't get brought up in
conversation a lot
so take whatever your interests are and
then find a really interesting way to
like
phrase it okay so that it invites
conversation okay
um that's a good picture
i wouldn't that i can't see anything
there that's uh me falling on a bike
oh okay that looks like a fail video
from like
uh what's it called e-bombs world that's
me and
uh kevin abstract i saw him at a concert
oh cool okay
that's me and taylor lautner when i was
a sophomore it's just yeah well don't
put this
don't put this picture what is this it's
the entire lot in here
yeah but do you want them to look at
taylor lautner you want them to look at
you
i kind of agree with that and also you
look like a kid they're gonna feel like
a pedophile
mistake taylor lautner for me no you
gotta remove this yeah you look like a
kid in this
um it was me and my dog that's a cool
picture yeah dog pictures
you gotta take a cuter picture of your
dog dude come on
one red eyes yeah this dog looks like it
should be cute but this picture is not
very flattering i would take a good one
with your dog oh this is cool i like
this picture
there's my dog again like if you're
gonna
put a picture of a dog let's get one
that's really clear and cute
this one he looks like i'm like a ghost
yeah there's my tortoise biting my toe
that's odd i didn't know that was up
there yeah
honestly you there's me interesting i
think you have a lot of odd pictures in
here
um see you said i gotta give them a
taste of who i am yeah yeah
i would just put like two of these and
not
the the majority shouldn't be odd
pictures right
you know because at the end of the day
tinder is as
much as i hate to say it is a very
superficial thing like they want to see
what you look like
right and i think there's only like two
pictures in there that show what you
actually look like taylor lautner one
exactly yeah no not even the taylor the
taylor lottery one you look like you're
eight
yeah okay that makes sense um and then
and then maybe put like two or three
weird ones
but like you should have pictures that
show what you actually look like
um because that's what they want to see
interesting yeah i agree
okay that makes sense i've made some
adjustments but dude you have such a
yeah you have such an interesting life
like it would be
it would be a waste to not talk about
all those things in your profile
huh and you don't have to do it in like
a really like see i think for me because
i'm asian people have this perception of
asian people being like really shy and
introverted
so i almost have to overcompensate
that's what i found in the past at least
um because you're white i'm guessing
you're just
straight up american white yeah um
because of that you might want to play
down a little bit i don't know depends
on your personality
but there's still ways to say hey i'm
really interested and i have this great
life without being like
super braggy about it right huh oh we
got our visitors oh we got the cavs we
got ramsay
cute i appreciate that advice yeah i
mean
like dude don't i i'd say just don't be
afraid to put yourself
out there um yeah like brag in a way
that makes you feel comfortable but
let people know what you have going on
dude to be honest i kind of
have the app right now a lot of it is
just kind of as a novelty
because i do enjoy just kind of going on
it and stuff i don't i'm not really like
i don't really meet up with people and i
don't really carry conversations i kind
of just have it because i think i think
it's really fun
but let's say let's say i meet someone
in person okay can we do some role
playing yeah
yeah let's do it okay so i guess
i'll be the no graham graham of course
would be the girl okay
and you would be approaching graham
let's say a grocery store
okay and graham is wearing an outfit
that you like
okay here why don't you approach graham
and then
and then and then i'll give you the
critique okay okay because you can see
me doing it on youtube
all right go for it jack okay i've never
done this before
uh pressure's on pressure's on okay
hey ma'am hi i just wanted to say i
think that your outfit's really nice
oh thanks dee
do you want to go d i like your
what's your name what's your name
uh graham that's a very pretty name
do you come here often i i may have seen
you before i
gotta go i'm gonna hurry
okay so how did i do um okay so first
off i wouldn't call someone
i wouldn't call someone mam that's not
that's number one but i try to think of
other words but lady sounded even
weirder you just don't
use any noun like that just don't use
any nouns
um um and then second would be
i you know i try to stay away from
generic
like you look like i like your outfit um
the
the the what you start with doesn't
really matter it's really how you
continue
right because no matter what you say
it's gonna
it's gonna they're either gonna be like
down to talk or not maybe she's in a bad
mood maybe she's like i'm in a hurry and
am i
to talk to you like f off so um
i think for for for me all right you
want to you want to do a
you want to do a second role play sure
all right do you want to you on me yeah
okay okay
all right um let's see
so what is she wearing i would look for
something situational i'm just gonna
sure um so let's say we're
standing in line well you know the first
thing i noticed is watch i would say or
her watch
i would say that watch looks expensive
that's hilarious ah thanks appreciate it
how much was that like 10 000 bucks it's
a gift from who
subscriber oh you make youtube videos
yeah
i do you watch youtube i teach i teach
people how to make youtube videos oh no
way
small world that's what's your channel
graham stefan
oh cool see now i would say like have
you heard of like graham steph or
whatever and get into this conversation
right but now it's more conversational
versus like you're going and hitting on
that was actually pretty good man
so it's a holy mackerel that's a good
that's a good
uh it's just a comment like that
yeah like i don't i generally you know
because when you go up and compliment
somebody um some some
women will just have like a shield up
like oh he's sitting on me i can't
like i can't deal with this and it gets
them to be kind of uncomfortable some
are really confident about it and
they're like hell yeah like
i'm totally down to talk to people um
but i think when you make more of like a
situational comment like that and you're
trying to be a little bit more
you know creative or funny with it it
gets them to open up a lot more easily
wow that was good man that's crazy wow
yeah
and the best the best time to do it is
like uh
at like bars or or um you know if you're
like hanging out with a bunch of friends
and you just kind of see someone you
just kind of start talking to them
it's really easy because if they kind of
turn away you're you know you're still
there with your friends and it's totally
fine
um whereas i think a lot of people put a
lot of pressure on these kind of things
where they're like all right
i see this really attractive person
whether it's a guy or a girl like i see
this
attracts person i gotta go talk to them
and then they get in their head and then
they're like oh my god
i gotta do it they walk up they go nope
hold on i can do this i can
and it just becomes like this whole
thing whereas if you make it more of a
casual thing
and you start talking casually now
you're just a normal human being that's
starting a conversation right and if
it's
a good conversation you can say hey you
seem really really fine let's
get coffee sometime or let's get dinner
sometime
jeez yeah that's what happens when you
do it when you know when you do those
kind of things for like 10 years wow
what other questions do you have jen we
got the mask
this is this is like uh i should be
charging for this the second
i don't know i i feel i i feel like i
feel weird because i
also feel like don't you think that our
audience would want to redirect
to like finance maybe me let's get back
to let's get back to the personal
finance just just in case
we make sure we cover all the bases
that's true you could always cut it out
what's your credit score my credit score
i haven't checked in a while but i
believe it's 780 790.
that's fantastic how many credit cards
do you do you know what's funny is
my credit score was like really before i
started watching your channel
because wow um you have to understand
like i dropped out of college not
knowing any of this personal finance
stuff
okay so i started making money really
really easily or not easily but like
really quickly compared to a lot of
other people oh yeah and i didn't really
know how to manage it
so i just had it sitting in a bank for a
very long time um
uh sometimes i was late on my credit
card payments not because
i couldn't pay it just because i like
forgot and i didn't give a [ __ ]
um and then it wasn't until i started
watching your channel that i was like
oh wow you can credit card hack and get
all these
free all this free season your ad spent
i could only imagine
um so our ad spend was it was fine
because we got two percent back cash
unlimited
um so so that was fine and for for a
startup that's
cash is better than points right um
but there were a lot of like everything
before that we didn't get
we literally just used like a bank of
america credit card wow it was crazy
and so it wasn't until you know watching
your channel and a few other channels on
youtube too that i was like oh my gosh
i've been doing this wrong my whole
life right because i didn't care what my
credit was i didn't care like what
credit card i used
i didn't understand the the benefits you
get from this
and ever since like maybe two three
years ago
i started really paying attention to
that and my credit is is great now
that's awesome so how much are you
saving now did your financial habits
change
over time yeah yeah for sure you know
one thing that
really changed for me you know maybe its
age
part of it is definitely kind of like
watching you and your channel and
i i really loved how you have this like
almost pride in being really cheap and
not spending that much money and i was
like fun
that's pretty cool man because the when
when i was kind of like
an up-and-coming youtuber i'm hanging
around like these pranksters right
fans like these people who are just like
living at large
and so i always felt like to be to fit
in i
i also have to do that and um
recently my mindset has really changed
on now
i'm kind of on your side where it feels
good to save money oh yeah i take that
to
almost almost an extreme now where you
know i'll go to an arcade with
with some friends and they'll want
drinks but it's like i brought my own
vodka in my belt
it's funny i talked about that in a
video too i mentioned that's one of the
ways to save money i'm like if you're
gonna go to the bar and get a drink
uh don't get the drink yeah and and
bring
your own i mean i don't want to endorse
people sneaking things in anywhere but
yeah or or if you want to do it real
legit
you can just drink beforehand go there
maybe get a diet coke or something
right chill and or maybe a beer like for
five bucks
um and then and then you don't have to
waste money on alcohol i used to when i
went out i would spend like two hundred
dollars
a night wow are you serious yeah cuz
think about it if you go to a
club in hollywood right it's like 15 a
drink
and then if you buy it for five friends
that's already like 60 70 bucks
um so imagine you're going to multiple
bars a night and you're going why are
you paying for all your five friends
though they can't
get their own drinks um so it depends
sometimes uh
usually my friends will buy buy their
own drinks but if people are
coming in for example to visit then i
always feel like hey i should buy you a
drink or something like that
yeah but it's not like i'm going out
buying myself look at you fancy you five
friends
but yeah man now now i am um
i basically have the mindset of
every single dollar that i save is or
that i spend
is a dollar that's not making me more
money yeah right i literally learned
that from your videos that's why i was
so excited to be on this podcast i was
like i've really learned a lot from you
you've changed my perspective this is so
cool yeah um and now so
so my story is not the only story like
that um
a lot of youtubers who are up and coming
and they
suddenly get this crap ton of money are
in the same position right i talked to
tons of people who are like
hey kong yeah i'd like like this one guy
um
well i shouldn't say his name but he
basically um he went through our course
got successful and now he's making you
know
he he has his own course too and now
he's making like every single launch
fifty thousand dollars
a thousand dollars something like that
he was like i don't know what to do with
it i was like watch graham stefan's
channel
thanks man dude that's awesome that
makes me really happy to hear yeah cause
you know you go through look i went
through business school for like three
four years
and they didn't teach you any of that
they taught you stupid stuff like how to
segment your market and all this stuff
and i'm like i'm never gonna use that
yeah no they don't teach you the most
important thing which is
when you have money how do you save it
how do you invest it so that you're not
losing value from that money every
single year by leaving it in your bank
account
and i'll teach you that stuff right um
so i think it's really important you
know what you're doing and it's it's
really changed my perception on do you
have a rate now that you save like 50
you try to save 60 percent um
no i don't get as meticulous as that um
but generally speaking i just
don't spend that much anymore okay um
i'm also getting old now so
you know i used to party a lot and now
my body can't really handle it
so i'm pretty responsible with it i
really will only spend money when
uh when it's justified like you know i'm
going
going to like some event with my friends
or you know it's dinner for
for a friend's birthday or something
like that where are you investing now
where is it all going so i want to say
out of everything i have invested
probably um
60 of it is in index funds cool um or
similar like some of it is in uh what's
it called
oh my gosh i always forget smb 500. no
no it's the wealth front well
okay cool you know it's a glorified
index fund sure
and then 20 of it is
invested in tesla
um just because i've done a lot of
research on that company and after i
bought a tesla i said
there's no way this is not going to be
the future what price did you buy in
tesla
i mean i'm still buying like every week
but if you took the average
probably around five six hundred
something like that
pre-split pre-split pre-split yeah it's
pretty cool
that's not bad one of the cameras oh man
oh yeah so so 20 yeah so 20 is on tesla
and then
what else the other what are we at 80 so
the other 20
is more like a little bit more high risk
investments so i've invested in a couple
of startups
um and then i also have a little bit of
cryptocurrency
probably like around five to seven
percent something like that got it
yeah do you have any goals for the next
five years like net worth goals
or income goals or like what's the next
thing you want to hit
um you know my goals are always not
monetary
to be honest so i think with the
creative agency
we want to create an ad that
is really well respected within the ad
world
so maybe it gets featured on ad week or
like one of these like advertising
magazines
um i think that would be a really great
goal for for us to hit um
and then with the with the linkedin for
for video creators platform
i would like 1 000 people to
to be on it that are like hardcore fans
um
so you know we have a decent number of
people on it but we're still developing
features figuring out what people want
there's nobody that's coming back every
single day to use it yet because it's
still in beta
but if we could get a thousand people
that's literally coming back every day i
would be super happy with that
because that's a pretty good sign of
you're getting close to product market
fit yep
when did you start investing so i i
invested in a lot of like
risky stuff beforehand to be honest
because i didn't know what else to do
with my money
um but i started like investing in the
index funds and stuff after i watch your
channel actually so
there was like two three years ago
something like that um back when you
were at like 50 000 subscribers i was
like
crazy guy knows what he's talking about
you know you know because the thing is
everybody tells me
to to invest in index funds but the way
that you described it
of like okay uh 99 percent of it you
know the market beats 99 of investors
yep and
no matter how you time the market like
it's always better it's generally just
better to just invest
yeah consistently every single month and
get in early and after i watched a
couple of those videos
videos of yours i was like that just
mathematically makes sense
that's literally mathematically just
makes sense yeah so i'm gonna do that
from now on
um so it was probably around two or
three years ago that i
started like actual investing and being
smart about it
what were some of the risky investments
you made um
i got uh i got
so it's okay now but
i invested in a startup two years ago
that was pretty risky to be honest um
and it was a
pretty large amount of money the
company's called flex uh we made an ad
for them
anyway so i invested in them uh that was
like a risky investment quote-unquote
because it's a start-up right at the end
of the day
start-ups can you tell us how much you
invested yeah uh it was fifty thousand
dollars
okay um in into their company um and
this was like basically their seed round
so
they're doing really well now but after
i made that ad for them um i was like
i gotta invest in this company it's it's
too good they have a patent on it they
bought out their other competitor
and um it's just great but i think in
the grand scheme of things considering i
just had money in the bank and i wasn't
doing anything with it
that is quite a risky investment have
you made money on that
no no i mean as with any startup you
don't make money until they get sold or
they ipo
right so it's not gonna be it's gonna i
mean is it worth more than 50 grand now
yeah you have to be
yeah yeah yeah well they were worth a
certain valuation
uh when i invested the 50 grand but yeah
it's now it's higher yeah it's now it's
definitely higher
okay so on paper at least you made a
little money so far yeah exactly
and like give it to some other investor
no i mean
technically you could but it's pretty
it's pretty hard to do that unless
they're like a super hot company like
when uber was coming up you know and
nobody could get in
um but but uh no it's generally pretty
hard to do that
let's do a quick millennial money on you
so
could you say some expenses that you
think that you that you've had in the
past that you think
graham would not approve of oh i have
i have a lie oh yeah let's hear it yeah
um
i want to hear it so i just hear how bad
this is if there's anything that's bad
that you think is just
you look back now and you're like i
regret spending that much money
there's so many okay you guys are gonna
be here for five hours
um top five so the first one is
definitely
going to the bar and buying drinks like
that's just so expensive it's ridiculous
um like every night i would go out
i would probably buy around let's say
like eight drinks
at fifteen dollars each so you're
talking about a hundred dollars a night
and then um this is not including like
you know if we were
partying getting like bottle service or
something like that too now is this so
this is a
write-off i'm assuming because well yeah
everything was a write-off back then
right right um that's how i justified it
because it was a write-off
um but uh jeez
that and then what else um
i was always by the way that sober
friend because i refused
to go and get a drink at the bar i did
not want to do it yeah
yeah that's smart i refused and uh if
that meant i would drive everybody fine
but i just did not want to spend the
money i i distasted that
so much well now i just bring it in my
in my belt
and put a water bottle in there yeah and
then i get a diet coke and then i just
kind of pour some in
um not that i recommend doing that right
it's pretty shady but
you know that's who i am i admit it so
who else
um okay so drinks was definitely a big
one i would say travel was a really big
one too because i love travel
but i didn't know how to credit card
hack and travel like i do now
so i was paying for like business class
tickets
to places wow right so like um you know
going to new york for example flying
business class i'd pay like two thousand
two thousand five hundred dollars geez
yeah it was ills nuts man um
that was that was a really big one um
spending
spending on travel and and not travel
hacking
designer close i never really got into
designer clothes
uh to be honest uh see for me when i
spend money i always spent money on
experiences
um like these more material items
weren't that important to me
um so if they had no function to it i
generally wouldn't spend that much money
there were a couple items that i did
that i splurged on but
i don't think there's nothing that i'm
not proud of in terms of like clothing
well it doesn't seem like you're too you
were too crazy on spending or anything
it sounds like
no no yeah it wasn't like yeah it wasn't
like i was spending way more than
i should have it was just like i wasn't
smart about it that's all
yeah um so those that's two what was the
third one
what about rent housing thinking about
should i say this or not
um that's a yes
so if it's pg-rated you should say it
oh no it's definitely pg i'm just
talking about from like a legal
perspective
um okay so rent was actually usually
fine because i uh
i spent i spent a lot on rent but um
most of it was written off
at office yeah as an office because back
then when i was making youtube videos i
was literally using
most of my apartment yeah you know for
vlogs
marketing materials that kind of thing
um could i have spent less on rent
yeah probably um but i don't necessarily
how much was rent rent at its highest
was
thousand dollars wow i think i remember
that place because it had a view was
hollywood or downtown it looked like
yeah yeah um uh it was in hollywood
uh and uh well six thousand i only paid
that for like six months because
i was living month to month it was
usually around five thousand
uh prior to that wow yeah like four to
five thousand depending on which floor i
lived and where i moved
the mortgage here by the way just the
mortgage i think is fifty now it's fifty
two hundred dollars a month
for the mortgage wow yeah this is what i
put a lot down
this is way bigger without property tax
well you know yeah in hindsight
i wish i had just bought a house yeah
right because i didn't understand
because i was like you know what i don't
want to buy a house
this was literally my mindset i was like
i don't want to buy a house because i
don't want to pay the interest
like that's how that's how that's how
stupid i was yeah i was like i don't
want to pay interest i'm just going to
save up until i
can buy the whole house in cash i didn't
understand
that you could use the money that you
don't spend on the house to invest in
the market and you're making more than
the interest that you're paying right
right or at the very least and that's a
write-off exactly yeah i didn't know any
of these things
right so my my justification was
i'm just gonna spend spend the money on
this baller apartment and i'm gonna save
up until i can buy a house in cash
that was my goal um i know better now so
now i'm looking for uh now i'm looking
for a house there we go
in in the worst time possible it's tough
but you know what i think good deals are
to be had
they're they're out there you just got
to look they take forever to find yeah
yeah i'm sure
i have not found a good deal in la since
i started looking
oh i started seriously no not seriously
but i i wanted to buy another like i
wanted to buy an office space originally
here
and i've been looking since march
nothing
there's one that i loved that was a big
like
open concept spot i'll show it to you
afterwards but
uh it's sold so a little bit higher than
what i was willing to pay for it okay
got it it worked out in the end how do
you calculate that though because
if it's a little bit higher than you're
willing to pay but you're willing to
keep it for like 10 years
doesn't that just justify like the the
higher price as long as you
enjoy the property not really i felt
there was a cap in terms of
the value that i would get from it
versus how much i'm willing to tie up in
that property it's a
it's a really unique space that's been
on the market for like a year
and you just need one specific buyer for
that
and so i was worried that in the event i
needed to sell it or get a tenant it
would be
really hard to get a tenant or a buyer
so that's what you mean
so there's just a risk that i figured
i'm willing to take a risk up to a
certain dollar amount and then anything
over that it just
it doesn't pencil out in case something
were to happen i see what you mean okay
okay that makes sense yeah i got it did
we ever
get uh because i don't honestly i don't
remember but did did you ever say
exactly how
what what you used to be able to to exit
your shell or to be able to
to turn to an extrovert do we not
really um i so yeah in order to get out
of my shell i
i talked about the game and it really
just came down to
literally going out and talking to
random people on the street and at bars
and just doing it yeah like i literally
just did that but how uncomfortable was
that for you
extremely uncomfortable at first like i
was that guy that was like oh my god i
can't believe i'm doing this
getting away with your friends yeah go
go yeah yeah essentially
you know and um and uh like
it was just really really hard for the
first year or two of doing that because
i forced myself to go out there
and it wasn't even just like i was
trying to get girls numbers i was
literally
talking to random dudes i was literally
talking to old ladies i was literally
talking to old men
like i would force myself to go do those
things and even when i was an old lady i
would like
yeah you know i i would be like drenched
in sweat he'd be like that looks
expensive
yeah yeah looks like an expensive watch
but um yeah just doing that so many
times
i came to the realization that um
that you just need to have fun with it
you know i met a few people along the
way that were just kind of like really
naturally
good at talking to people out at the
bars and out in public
and um i realized that this is not
really something that you have to be
like mentally prepared for
you have to have scripted lines it's a
mindset right it's a mindset of
i don't care what other people think
about me i'm gonna go out and have fun
and if you don't respond to me in a
positive way then i don't care i have my
friends over here i can go back to my
great life that i'm living and so um it
almost came down to me
accepting that i have a good life
and being proud of who i am versus like
uh i hate who i am and i have to impress
people when i meet them
if that makes any sense that makes sense
um so it was a mindset shift and once i
had that mindset shift and i went out
and
stopped caring about what people think
and found like
you know when if i got rejected i
started finding that
totally okay um that's when everything
changed for me
and what about now do you ever get
nervous now when you're testing yourself
or is it all just so easy for you
um no i don't i don't get nervous i
would say the closest
is like if i you know if i see somebody
who i really look up to like for example
if uh
i saw i don't know graham stefan yeah
or if i saw like i don't know elon musk
or something and we're at some
networking event i'd be like oh
like you know i get a little bit excited
but i don't think i'm ever like
nervous to the point where i'm drenched
in sweat like i was before
so you think you cured it you think you
got over that
hurdle is it like riding a bike where
once you get over it then you never have
to worry about it again
i don't think so um i think it's very
similar
to to like working out you know you
always have that voice in your head that
says like
you can't do this you're worse than them
um you suck
uh whatever and it's kind of like
working i was like no i don't want to go
today i'm too tired
i'm too lazy like i got too much stuff
to do you're always going to have that
voice
but you get better at dealing with that
voice and
um and and and you know how to handle it
if that makes sense
so you're so i always have that those
like thoughts going into a situation
like that
but i'm just better uh i just handle it
better now than i did before yeah
so kong thank you so much for coming on
this has been really fun
really good advice and we'll report back
to you on jack's tinder profile all
right
excited to hear about it so pleasure
meeting you with that said you guys
thank you so much for watching i really
appreciate it make sure oh you got to
tell them to destroy the like button for
the youtube algorithm look right in that
camera right there and say destroy the
like all right i want you guys to do one
thing for me right now
just one thing and that is to destroy
and demolish that like button right now
for the youtube algorithm we should get
a compilation together
of everyone every guest being like
destroy the like button that was a good
one
i almost i almost wanted to say that
like seductively but then
i was like i don't think that's g-rated
tell the like button how expensive it is
uh make sure to obviously subscribe you
can add us on instagram links down below
in the description and now weeble by the
way brought back the promotion
of two free stocks they did and now
it's even better this is the best offer
they've ever had both free stocks that
you're gonna get are valued at minimum
eight dollars and all the way up to one
thousand
six hundred dollars so yeah it's
actually a really good deal
back uh back in the old day the first
stock was only like two dollars
uh and the second stock was eight now
they're both minimum eight dollars so if
you want those two free stocks
claim them down below in the description
and let us know which two free stocks
you get
thank you so much for watching and until
next time until next time
cool excellent
yes cool all right let's make sure i'm
in frame here yeah there we go
scoot over oh no you're just okay right
there okay cool now you're good you're
good you're good cool let's start
you want to you want to intro us graham
uh yeah what episode are we 20th
how much has a podcast made so far it's
5700 700 okay
that's a good amount yeah wow 19th you
said
20th 20th okay uh look into this one